svetlana savchenko smiles warmly her
wheelchair takes up the majority of her
living room
my home that is region but there is no
one
her cat busia her only companion her
husband and son died years ago twice a
month the volunteer from harkief hub
swings by and drops off a small plastic
bag with a few items there's not much
inside yet she's grateful
the world bank estimates the number of
ukrainians living below the national
poverty line could reach 70 percent this
year it was 18 percent in 2021
volunteer drivers have had their cars
struck with shrapnel but each week they
get behind the wheel delivering an
average of 1500 small parcels
local businesses are supporting the
effort along with unicef but the
coordinator of the harkief hub says
there are too many elderly and disabled
residents suffering there are so many
stories that can hurt you
this heart
warm
it's terrible things and there are many
of terrible things to extend their reach
the volunteers launched rescue me
sponsors can read different profiles and
pick someone to rescue
ensuring they'll receive food and
medicine
[Music]
ukraine does provide financial
assistance to elderly and disabled
people but it's not much those with
moderate disabilities for example
receive roughly 2 500 griebna per month
that's less than 90 canadian dollars
it is desirable to help
now for eight people this bag must be
divided survival for many in ukraine is
a fight happening far from the front
lines
crystal gavinson global news jar keith